[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is James
Marsden James Marston how did how did
this happen this is truly incredible
I've run into uh old Jimmy boy I'm
already calling him Jimmy boy it's our
it's only the intro I'm calling him
Jimmy Morris Jimmy Morris and I have run
in our paths have crossed a few times
over the years and it's always a delight
running into him uh but I was a little
nervous asking him to do the show he's a
movie star for crying out loud
The Notebook ever ever heard of it X-Men
he's Cyclops and here he is on you made
it weird I'm thrilled he's also on a new
show which is on Amazon freebie uh which
is going to drop in two days on April
7th it's called jury duty on freebie
it's hilarious it's incredible that's
his newest thing you got to check it out
starting on April 7th I believe four of
the episodes will be dropping on April
7th then you'll be able to watch new
episodes every Friday until April 21st
so check out jury duty with our boy
Jimmy Mars uh and I feed also like to
see some Live Comedy I'm on I'm on the
road go to petehomes.com if you'd like
to come and see me do stand up or go to
largo-la.com if you're going to be in
the LA area I do a monthly show at the
Largo theater so there's a good chance
I'm doing a show uh I believe the next
one is May 4th like Star Wars Day May
the fourth be with you that's going to
be excellent uh or go to peedoms.com and
see where I'm going to be traveling
killing two in the meantime I don't know
why I said it like that if you are new
to the show I only do sponsors that I
actually use and actually love like our
friends at Living Libations this episode
is brought To Us by those friends at
Living Libations my whole life I was
careful about what I was putting in my
body but I was never really careful
about what I was putting on my body when
it came to moisturizing or toothpaste or
hair products or skin products eye
products Dental products baby products
and obviously those things when you just
buy them off the racket at some random
Pharmacy they're filled with toxic
chemicals they're filled with stuff that
isn't good for you that gets on your
skin into your bloodstream into your
body so enter living Libations to help
meaning you can have incredible
wonderful great acting great acting I
just mean effective powerful skin care
hair care baby care that you look at the
ingredients and you recognize every
single thing on the list it's
unbelievable I want to eat food where I
reckon nice the ingredients and I want
my skin and Beauty care to be exactly
the same it's skin care it's Beauty care
that you can feel great about putting on
in your body keeping you healthy keeping
you looking vibrant keeping you looking
alive beautiful whatever you want to say
whatever words what poetry moves you
today we use their best can ever
moisturizer both Val and I a bottle
lasts many many many many months just a
couple literally two little beep beep
the whole face completely moisturized
glowing beautiful and you can you can
read the ingredient you get it living
Libations is a great way to support the
show whatever you've got in your
medicine cabinet or on your next year's
sink living Libations has a high-end
premium natural replacement for whatever
you got so this is a great way to
support the show pick one of those
products replace it I promise you'll
love it it'll be super effective and you
can feel good about putting it on in
your body so go to living libations.com
weird you'll get 15 off
livinglibations.com weird do your body a
favor and show your support of the show
livinglabations.com weird we're also
brought To Us by our friends at on it
everybody knows I love new trophy new
atropics and on it Alpha Brain is the OG
and I absolutely love it
absolutely swear by it what is it it's
Earth grown ingredients that helps you
with memory concentration and focus so I
don't know much about you but whatever
you're doing if it involves your brain
you could probably use to give yourself
a little bit of an edge it's not like
caffeine it's not a stimulant it doesn't
give you energy it doesn't get you all
jacked it gives your body the brain the
nutrition that it needs to concentrate
to dial in to focus and to create so
whenever I'm doing stand up doing this
podcast sitting down to write a script
or just going like literally it's
Saturday night Val and I are going to go
on a date I take a couple Alpha brains
before I go out because I like to be
able to listen engage access my
vocabulary access my memories and
stories and just be a good full brained
person so this is a secret weapon in my
life it's made a huge change I wish I
knew about it in college it would have
made such a difference when I had to
memorize stuff but now I'm memorizing
lines I'm memorizing different things
around there from a job makes a huge
difference if you like Alpha bread in
one tenth as much as I like it you're
gonna [__] your pants go to on it o n n
i t.com slash weird I've moved up to
their Black Label that's I just updated
my subscription it's easy to update your
subscription I love the Black Label it's
just a slightly more optimized formula
love it on it.com slash weird get your
brain working I'm making up these
slogans get your brain working and
working better with on it.com slash
weird alright everybody enjoy the
incredible James Marsden
it depends do you like listening to the
show
yeah
sorry I do love the sound of my own
voice right
it's like when you do
voice over yeah forgive me idea do you
have like a famous voiceover guy you do
I gotta go if you don't if you don't if
you don't know by now if that's a
question we got a long road ahead of us
are you entangled are you you're no no
you're not Tangled we had the guy from
Tangled the guy from the Tangled yeah I
call him the guy Flynn Rider that's
right you would have been a great Flynn
Rider
um we sort of I did uh I did Enchanted
and there was some voice over work in
that so half of it mostly live action
that's right and some of it was some of
it was animated I see but it was very
brief you know tell me if this is your
experience I tell people that that do
voice over
when you're first starting because
you've been doing this for
20 years more 30 30 years yeah I mean
the first 10 wasn't really doing it
was ten right when you would go in a
booth and you'd hear your own voice it
would actually kind of freak you out it
would make you bad I didn't like that no
no it became because if the the fewer
distractions you have the more focused
you're going to get on all of your
insecurities in every every like every
yeah you're literally in a coffin like
someone stood a coffin up you're like
I'm examining under a microscope this
element of your talent or lack thereof
that's right and it's your voice tell me
a story like this Jamesy Mars I'm so
happy to see you yeah good to see you
thank you making me very happy should I
keep these on or does it matter I think
mine were just a little distorted it
sounded like the 90s okay well I feel
like I'm trying to be cooler than you by
keeping mine it's a power move you can
hear a subtlety the power move is the
crisscross applesauce which I've never
been able to do here on this couch what
are they what material are these pants
that you're able no chiffon is that a
real material
um chiffon Daniels she was very flexible
you can't save it and Von Daniels is not
a real person so you can say it you can
say whatever you want about chiffon you
have no idea what this fabric is tell me
a story about this because this actually
just happened to me this past week have
you ever auditioned for something I know
you have 30 years yeah and you leave and
you're in your car and you go I know I
can do better than that and go back or
try to like put yourself on tape doing
it again or anything like that has there
ever been like a sweaty I can't cite an
example of what I didn't do that
most of my experience has been only that
it's been a lot of like second guessing
and like if only I had just calmed down
for me I was like why didn't I just calm
down right you're doing I just did it
I'm doing a monologue and I had done it
for my wife which is so different it's
like honey please sit here and just let
me do this model yeah I'm so comfortable
with her then you get on the zoom I'm
going like it's like listening to a
podcast 3x speed I can hear it yeah I'm
too fast I'm it sucks yeah tell me a
story like that about auditioning if you
have if something comes to mine well you
always by Nature you do by the nature of
auditioning you leave second guessing
not only your career but your life
yeah yeah yeah
we live in a beautiful new house we just
moved I'm walking around I'm like I
don't deserve this because I just ate
[__] yeah
well because it's designed to I mean
it's not designed to be like you're on
set right you're you're in a a
windowless box with a with a camcorder
pointed at you if they even make those
anymore I mean it was for me I think
they do uh and a couple of Suits if that
even just like you walk in and it's
judgment and immediately and you're
self-aware and they just heard it yeah
so for you oh yeah there's like 20 other
people before you yes right they're
tired of hearing it yeah and you're
getting panicked yeah I said I got the
way that I could feel my inner Defender
like the part of me that's being like no
it's them was like go ahead hire someone
who's good at auditioning I'm good at
all right that's a good angle yeah it's
a good way to avoid the pain yeah so I
was like [__] you so I can't do an
emotional scene and over Zoom with no
one but I know I could do it on set talk
a little bit about the difference
between if you sorry this isn't Larry
King live we're just talking no no but
the difference between being good at
auditioning whereas you know on set you
can take a moment to get your heart open
or get in the zone or relate with your
scene partner or or even just put the
Wardrobe on again you know I mean all
those little things help the trailer
you're getting in care you're literally
getting it you've got the job and you've
got that and you've got the job they're
hiring you to be confident and then they
put you in the least confident situation
you can't do it I can't stand yeah no I
mean I was always and sometimes that
would flip sometimes I got I remember
feeling at times somewhat cocky about
auditioning like I was because there was
no there was nothing to lose because
there was no job I didn't have the job
yet that I could kind of go in and you
know put Tunnel Vision on and sort of be
flashy and then once you get the job
you're like oh
well now there's Stakes now they're
paying and it used to be like film in
the camera I remember that like yeah hey
we're rolling film and it's like
hundreds of dollars
as you're sucking yeah needing five more
tickets literally exposing this on
precious we're on on strips of plastic
so delicate they can't be shown the
light but we're putting your face
sucking permanently emblazing like the
face of Christ on your toes is
emblazoned on this and it sucks yeah
yeah yeah you're like can we shoot this
back in the auditioning room yes no but
I'm with you a callback is the same for
me it's not just so for this one I
didn't suck and I did a good job and
they were lovely I really I'm not just
saying that to Kiss the Ring it was a
good experience but the audition I was
like you I was like [__] this it's
stupid I did it with no care right first
take yeah looking at the sides the whole
time just kind of being me get the call
back and now I'm like well now it's real
right how do I not care again and not
give how do I not give a [__] right they
wanted the guy that doesn't give a [__]
and now I give a [__] there's nothing
intriguing interesting funny Charming
likable watchable about a guy who really
wants you to like them
right it's the worst no no and then and
if you can master that if you can kind
of compartmentalize your thoughts and
and actually convince yourself that you
don't care yes if you get this job or
not is that something more often than
not yeah yeah more often than not you
get you know that that was something
that that was that that was attractive
to them how did you do that did you
literally just tell yourself yeah just
to pretend like you're yeah my role okay
so you're an actor and you're playing
the part of a guy who doesn't care right
who then plays a part of the guy that
would be in the movie right is that what
it is yeah yeah like Houdini says I'm an
actor who pretends to be a magician yeah
I feel like the president of the United
States whoever it is is an actor
pretending to be the President right act
presidential yeah right because it's all
about perception and how what you're
trying to think of what they want to see
and so yeah kind of putting on an act
yes and then you're like well if I get
the job of president or this role yes
then I'll actually turn on my real thing
right now is just like getting the fish
on the hook that's right right yeah and
the primary debate are like the Callback
that's right true you're going for a
part remember there was that Matt Damon
movie where he was a politician I forget
and he held up his shoe he was like we
surveyed this is the correct amount of
scuff to have on my shoe which I thought
was really interesting as a politician
who's campaigning too because you want
to look slick but not too small
to judge got [__] for I don't follow the
news but I saw it on Weekend Update they
made fun of that's news that's our news
that he was wearing two nicest shoes at
the train Calamity and they were like
that's how we are right right right yeah
but then you can also see it when it
becomes manufactured too right he's like
okay you're now you're now
dressing down to to do that it's such an
orchestrated thing like you said it's an
act yeah well comedians right I've said
this a million but I want to hear what
you think about it you watch uh I'm
trying to think of a non-scandalized
comedian I really just struck out God in
the DNA of it the person who it was was
Louie uh Louis had a bit about uh flying
on a plane Louis CK yeah and I was like
but this is after he was huge many
Madison Square Gardens and I was like
Lily you're flying private you know what
I mean I don't know if he really does I
don't know Louie but I'm just like you
tell these man of the people's stories
you're like you always get the middle
seat man you haven't seen the middle
suit if you see a middle seat it's like
so you can put the arms up and sleep
across the road on some magical limo
plane yeah but but we buy we're okay
with that in the same way that we know
politicians are being fake like Hillary
Clinton went too far with the hot sauce
in her bag right but ever everything is
hot sauce in her bag these people are an
Illuminati but they're eating quail egg
omelets you know what I mean of course
and then they go around even Bernie said
I love Bernie I'm just saying like of
course he lives in a nice house like
remember when they tried to like go oh
he has a sports car it's like of course
he does this is show business and that's
okay it's okay like why do these people
have to adhere to to I don't know they
just think it's a whole rack he's not
showing up from the coal mines and going
like I think I'm gonna run for office it
costs billions of dollars
right it's like also what what
exceptional people do you know that want
to get into that business anymore yeah I
don't know like what you don't you're
not getting paid you're not allowed
yeah I mean like a nice car or whatever
like it's like social media the life you
have social media colon the life your
life becomes a Facebook profile like an
Instagram profile right it's just that
and you have to get elected to get
anything done right like you can't voice
your real true opinions if they're too
not extreme but you know you have to
find there's an element of that in this
I I just wrote down funny things where I
was like well you worked with uh Ryan
Gosling this is just kind of a joke
abstract 80s sort of Brian De Palma
painting isn't it cool that's very good
is that drive drive we've been doing
this podcast so long that I when I was a
single man I was obsessed it's not that
I don't I'm not obsessed with drive but
especially when I was like 10 years ago
yeah really into drive had this made and
I was so I wrote this down I was like oh
maybe I'll ask him about Gosling maybe
I'll ask him about about Wahlberg just
like funny stories but then I was like
not saying we're politicians but you
can't go like let's say let's say Mark
Wahlberg is a tool I'm not saying he is
right you can't say that no right no
it's bad business
Bad Business bad Humanity well yeah
would want to put that out there that's
another version of being a little bit
politicized but politicians are just
telling me a Mark Wahlberg story
honestly Mark is the greatest you know
what I mean he's so fit he travels with
the gym
that sounds familiar that was a little
birdie the one percent of the one
percent we need to change this Trump
socialism
the fire department the Socialists
very good furniture
let's sort of piece together what this
guy looks like that's sort of a mess
well we have to keep the orange yeah the
face of Bernie because Trump is the hair
maybe the mittens
the photo of him at the inauguration was
it the inauguration he's like yeah just
grumpy old Bernie sitting there sitting
through it okay back to our point you
audition for the part of President you
don't get it another you type like you
have your uh actors that probably shadow
your career you know what I mean right
yeah you're in a pocket of these guys so
one of these other guys gets it let's
say it is Gosling gets your your part
you have to go to the party celebrating
that he got it right you know what I
mean yeah exactly James Marsden yeah
it's there with the mittens like [__]
this why do I have to be here right
sucks yeah I know I wouldn't want that I
wouldn't want that at all I I mean he's
by the way I can't speak very I'll open
my mouth widely when I know someone's a
great guy yeah right yeah I'll never
speak poorly about anybody it's like
feeling like I wouldn't want you to if
you did we
one of my funniest um this movie is so
good I saw that recently yeah great and
Tom the music was the cinematographer on
this incredible he did all the X-Men
movies
yeah incredible cinematographer and he
was okay when you direct if you want to
direct just call me I'm like I'm gonna
I'm gonna remember gotta do that yeah
and I remember seeing drive and I went
oh that's such a piece of work man it
was just a beautiful beautiful film
I mean iconic those up from the gear
shift yeah with with this well in
moments where the lights going on the
face yeah and dedicating like real like
the use of restraint right like like
nowadays we feel like we have to speed
everything up right no one's gonna take
any time and they made a movie that no
one was asking for like you know when
you say restraint
by the way Val if she my wife if she
listens to this she'll laugh because
every time I watch something I go the
restraint really always it's my top
compliment is because they're not it's
it's like we're saying bad acting is
guessing what you want and trying to
give it to you sweaty and being like
this
it sucks yeah same with filmmaking it
sucks movies like drive you feel like
someone made their dream like a dream
they had at night and they made it and
they showed it to you as opposed to the
death of art which is well we need to
the first 15 seconds have to be
action-packed right and then we have to
you know there has to be sex 30 minutes
in like this formulaic not or here's a
movie that's similar to this that did
really well so let's duplicate that and
well even even the movie box even the
poster art will be the same yeah because
we're sleepwalking through and going
like well that's like I'm thinking of a
movie that looked exactly like The
Italian Job That's a classic poster they
they're Ronan yeah
bless you for trying what a strange game
a movie that's like the Italian job
that's not but like Drive every once in
a while
we'll talk how do you feel about art as
it sounds like you you are a filmmaker
you want to do you have directed I have
not okay so you'd like to
what it what is your feeling on a world
that's chasing what's already worked
and not just that but if you do make
something new
it's almost been instagrammed like it's
like we need to hook them right we need
to boy it's everything every series
seems like a Boiling Pot like you have
to end the pilot with like Dad like just
to keep them all right going and I'm
almost done here but it's almost like
pornography it's it's giving you
everything you think you want right but
it's not subtle it's not actually
interesting and it doesn't surprise you
but you are
you know right no that's kind of what
the nature of it is now right it's like
if you if you do you know the concept of
having you know 10 times as many
platforms to watch television or movies
or whatever content you want you're
searching for on paper seems great
because this is like you can you know
the cream will rise at the top and you
whatever whatever you want to see you
can go find it because it'll either go
on Netflix or Hulu or this whatever this
is the Mad Men phenomenon AMC puts out
everyone's favorite show you know
remember like that was what you're
saying that was what happened but it
doesn't always work that way well it's
just it's you it just you start to
realize that you're
you're kind of you're having to chase
the audience's appetite and they're
insatiable right like especially with
binging right yeah like I was always
questioning whether or not that's a good
thing yeah here's the whole series you
can watch it in a night I think it ruins
everything right exception how excited
are you watching succession no I I it's
on on my on my list is over I'm JK I
don't like to watch anything I'm not in
it's oh you still have a lot to watch
quite a catalog
comedy me drama me I even dive into some
of those audition tapes when I just I
I haven't
horror movie yeah yeah uh yeah I mean
but how fun is it when a show like
succession everyone's gonna watch it on
Sunday at the same time we're gonna talk
about it through the week and talk about
it and what's gonna happen right right
and White Lotus was that way White Lotus
was that right yeah The Last of Us yeah
that way yeah right my daughter's really
into anime and she's in the show called
um uh was Attack on Titans she was in
the show no she was very into it in a
show on Netflix called Arcane and it was
I don't know I don't know why I brought
that specific example up but it was you
know I'm always preaching this like
restraint yes don't give them everything
they want when they want it and
sometimes most of the time those people
what they think they want they don't
really want it right like an example
Sonic the Hedgehog hit it right I mean
the first movie first movie my daughter
saw in the theater oh really Jimmy
Morrison
yeah yeah I mean that wasn't that was a
that was a scenario where it actually
ended up working but I remember having
those debates about hey the the original
concept art came out for the character
and it didn't look right yeah people and
the fans were like yeah upset I actually
started you did no no yeah I remember
being like that's a little weird right
yeah that's scary and I remember having
conversations with the director and the
producer and conversations that I didn't
you know I wasn't really invited to that
table because you know you're an actor
just showed up but stay in your lane and
your lane is the one that does the
loop-de-loop with the rings on it right
right okay sweetheart
go back to the makeup trailer you
delicate little thing we'll handle the
business it's like a lit cigarette at
you right right and give you a a
grasshopper like yeah but I mean you
know this idea that I mean that that
worked out like wait tell me the story
talk to them everyone was not you know
most people weren't happy with how the
the the character looked and I think
everyone was kind of right but for that
for that one example we're Paramount and
the director and everybody listened to
it and changed the the look of the
character really really rare and it's a
and it's a delicate dance like you don't
want to just go
you know we're in this world like you
know test screenings right yeah like I
had different beliefs on test screens
like you know is this a good thing if
the audience is saying well this needs
to change it's too slow it's too fast
it's whatever is not enough this you
know
sure they're the audience but what do
they know about filmmaking yeah right I
don't know sometimes it's like well this
is George We're not gonna let them come
in and direct the film you know like
what they're not equipped to do that but
I guess if you find that sweet spot of
like all right there's enough people
that think that this is a problem yeah
then you gotta listen to it well that's
what Sonic was the reason I mentioned
George Lucas is because I think he's an
example of too much not listening to the
fans right you can listen to the fans
too much that's what we've been saying
that that's a problem right but there is
a sweet spot to go like no you know
Greedo shot first you know yeah yeah uh
it's Han Solo right it bothers me on
shot first right they changed it to
Greedo shot him and then hunt shot back
how do you feel about that I feel
horrible right same I mean he's about
he's a he's a what is a a Smuggler right
he's a thief yeah yeah that's that's the
archetype he's the dangerous guy that
you meet after your aunt and uncle are
crisp right but now we're we're looking
back and rewriting history again like we
got to make this guy a better guy right
but Sonic was right I mean that was
right that it was like the Irishman it's
like they could have deep have you seen
the people that improved the Deep fake
of De Niro young De Niro oh no they
spend like 50 million it looks like crap
and and then the fans are like this is
how you do it you got to look it up oh
really yeah the fans produced something
people just it's fantastic it's 10 out
of 10. I'm done my career's over if of
course
I was like we're not gonna make movies
anymore it's just gonna be fans at home
making movies well that is a story like
uh you know Rockstar it's like if there
is someone in the crowd that can sing
better than the lead guy get them up
there right right but what you're saying
with test screenings are there's no more
experts expertise is over we just Listen
to Everybody right and that's how you
get a bunch of nonsense but there is a
uh yeah I mean you got to listen to some
of it if it's it but and again I I'm not
on this side of the creative process but
just you know philosophically I'm like
wait isn't art about
creating what you want to create having
a voice having a story having it you
know whatever it is and like you either
like it or you don't yeah but like I'm
not gonna let you do the Choose Your Own
Adventure thing and and navigate tell me
the product that I'm creating that's
right that product even bad word yeah
like the art that I'm creating yeah I
know that sounds lady Twitty but not at
all I'm going back to that conversation
about like I'm not sure it's a great
thing to like give the audience
everything they want all the time right
you know we'll take it to your your
craft as an actor
it's all Instinct so when I say Drive is
like a dream I mean they they accurately
one for one took something from their
subconscious and brought it into reality
there's always compromises things are
going to change but they did their best
like carrying a wet stone from the ocean
back to your Beach Blanket it was still
pretty wet right when you got there
right
wet right
um with you you're acting off of your
gut as well and when I worked with Judd
Judd Apatow he was all gut yeah there'd
be two choices and he'd be like it's
this and would be like why yeah right
and there was no he didn't give a Ted
Talk on why it was just because he was
having a dream right and he was letting
us in on his dream so you're an actor
and you have to do your scene and you
decide where to lean and when to bite an
apple or whatever it might be but you
don't want that done by committee you
don't want 50 people going like it's um
I believe at the Cummings I say it all
the time if you want the song Don't
dissect the Songbird like don't cut it
open yeah it's not going to sing great
so if you're
tell me a little bit about following
your instincts and getting in a place of
confidence I assume where you can trust
like yeah well I think it's just you as
in as an actor you inherently are
self-aware right you're always going to
be second guessing yourself I don't know
many actors who are like who who
approach seeing scene work and movies
and TV whatever like you would
um if you were you know buying a house
yeah you know I mean like or something
that you just I'm trying to think of an
example of like just like you know what
I'm an investment I'm gonna take a risk
on this and just watch right you know
it's either gonna be wrong or it's gonna
be right right and we're always going
because it's not a right or wrong thing
it's so subjective right right like it's
this is what I'm kind of feeling is
interesting Yep this choice that I'm
making here and hopefully you surround
yourself with to me like the safest
place you can be is in the hands of a
director and a team that you admire and
that has a proven track yeah that like
you know so I've always my my main goal
is always like to the best of my ability
and my opportunities I want to work with
the best directors in town you know
because if you can get if you can get in
front of their cameras you know you're
going to be taken care of because you
can do 10 different takes
and they're the ones figuring out which
one goes in the movie in the edit right
I think you can make it terrible
uh I don't know yeah right to be here
not to be I guess and then you fall down
and they you knock over a light that's
the one they use yeah right yeah well
you have to have been at premieres Jokes
Aside where you're like I can't believe
that's the take they use yeah or I can't
believe they cut this part which was the
part we all got the chills right or and
you and I keep a log in my head I'm like
oh that felt good yeah and again it's
hard to have objectivity about yourself
sometimes when you're doing it but but
you know it's it's always a little
disappointing when you watch it going uh
that feels like they were hustling to
get the movie made we were still
shooting it while the editor was putting
it together and the director kind of
went okay cool that's good I like the
editor's edit yeah but if I'm directing
something I'm going to I'm going to get
my hard hat on the pickaxe I'm going
into the my yeah to find look watch
everything together yeah and I don't
know I just think like you're not one of
the one of the great things about being
in front of the camera and not being
necessarily on stage is that you can go
in and you know you can sometimes you
can Frankenstein these monster these
performance together if oh my God and
and get a great performance but it's not
like every take has to be perfect right
it's like you kind of go okay that bit
worked this bit kind of you know I
figured I forgot the line or like yep it
kind of went off the rails because there
was a distraction or whatever or I tried
something and it didn't work yep you
know I was yeah I was wondering did
anything come to mind I did a guest star
on something recently and I was just
like well this guy's dumb I'm gonna kind
of give him just the slightest Keanu
Reeves voice just the slightest I was
really nervous about that I don't
normally do that I just play myself yeah
I was like I'm just gonna just be like
oh just a little
and the director came in after the
rehearsal was like it's a little Bill
and Ted's and I was like copy like
coffee right but that vulnerability yeah
I don't think that's talked enough about
the risks that you're taking right is
there a time when you did a a walk and
someone was like I mean hey Jimmy uh
let's cool it with the walk right it's
funny you say that I have a I have a
story that specifically about a walk yes
and it just it just triggered me wow the
the the the the the memory X-Men three I
came back uh if it was a smaller role in
the third movie I I left I was doing
brand singers Superman Returns so I
didn't have the schedule was tight it
was a whole kind of thing at the time
yeah I wasn't gonna be in the third
movie as much as I was supposed to be
but they brought me back to die
basically and well if you can't be in it
let's go you might as well might as well
make sure he's never in it again there's
you just go in the writer's room there's
a white boy that says kill cycles and
circled okay I'm excited about this guys
super excited nobody pitched against
this yeah have you read the comments
he's a he's a big character yeah
I know that because I was really into
cable because I liked X-Force and I the
first appearance of cable is as a baby
in an X-Men comic okay and I read that
somewhere I don't know where did I read
that in pre-internet where did I find
that information yeah and I looked in my
brother's thing and I found it page one
of the comic is a baby yeah and uh I say
you you're holding it I think it's you
this is when you realize you're
inferiorating safe hands you were in it
okay Peter uh sorry Dad of cable gets
killed in X-Men three days yes but um as
I'm I'm writing a Harley-Davidson and
I'm distraught and I'm upset because
Jean Gray's gone right and I don't know
if you remember the scene or not but and
I I parked the Harley and Brett Ratner
is directing the third movie
and I parked at Harley and there's this
little Hill I have to walk down to get
to this Shoreline where I scream and I
rip my glasses off and the the uh oh
yeah yeah yeah the beam rage yes beam
rage into screaming and then she comes
out of nowhere anyway Park the Harley
got the glasses on walking down the hill
and Brett goes cut he goes hey uh that's
good
which is always just that tone alone I'm
already dead that you're about to get a
walking note I'm dead it was so even
like once you park it like hop off the
thing and just kind of maybe see if you
can just give it a little more Swagger
and I was like well I'm not really in
Swagger mode but sure as the character
yeah yeah I get what you're saying in my
mind I'm thinking [__] I'm walking down
this hill like Don Knotts you know
you're like what do I look like is there
something weird when I walk do I you
know because you're you're a superhero
like you want to be cool and that's kind
of what he was saying
and I'm thinking
I'm not even thinking about the scene
I'm getting ready to do I'm thinking
okay walk cool yeah yeah yeah and I'm
trying to think of who why who has a
good walk did Paul Newman have a good
walk yeah you know Brando how did he
walk he's a good walk right I don't know
so I do it again and cut is it cool cool
um let's do it again and again no note
on like the acting or whatever it's just
he goes
walk like you just got off a Harley
I can't handle this like
got it is that did that help you I mean
I guess I don't know but it was like I
never felt like more aware and insecure
about my walk yeah yeah
that was a fun ride on that motorcycle
[Applause]
I need to get down to find my dead wife
you look like you're holding in a turret
is what he was saying it's like you're
killing yeah
I I don't I never find it funny making
fun of a stutter it's just I hate it
it's just it and because it's this thing
that's natural to you it's how you talk
right and how you walk very similar to
me in uh crashing whenever I had to just
walk down the street I hated it somebody
told me to do math in my head which I
did I would be like seven times seven is
and I'd so I wouldn't be thinking about
my wife what's like what we talked about
at the beginning of the show was like it
it voice over work right where you're
just you're in a void nothing no other
distraction is going on no awareness of
what you're wearing what your body's
doing yes it's just your voice my same
thing with a walk if if you're if you're
having to doing crashing and you're
walking and talking and swinging a
tennis racket or anything right and
there's [__] happening you you don't
have the bandwidth which is think about
your walk that's what Adam if you watch
Adam Driver what if you watch Like Girls
or something he's always like playing
with a bottle or something I think it's
to keep him out of his head that yeah
he's trying to get to that level of
instinct it's the hardest thing for an
actor to do the the if you're tasked
with one line yeah it's the hardest
acting you'll have to do because you
always think the hell out of it there's
no rhythm you can get into these
pretzels are making me thirsty if you
have to get out of the car if you have
to park the car get out of the car yeah
and walk up you know three steps and go
into a cafe yeah you'll figure out some
way of making that difficult that's
right wow I stopped the car too abruptly
and like I kind of clumsily got out and
fumbled with the keys and like all [__]
you wouldn't be doing if you had a scene
that you were immersed in
this is something else Chad said to me
is like you're so privileged because you
get to it was a show where I was in
every scene so he's like you just get to
do so much acting right it's like actors
don't really get to act that much
comedians can go out and do their craft
whenever they want if you want up a spot
but like if you haven't acted in a while
even though you've acted a lot right and
now it's only just just one scene of
course you're going to overthink the
hell out of it yeah of course but if you
were in every scene and it was just a
scene where you have to pull up to a
diner you'd do it like the good audition
which is you're right exactly like
probably what appeals to a lot of actors
who are on stage right like you get into
the Rhythm over and over again and and
it's not cut and disjointed and yeah and
you know but yeah the the the the well
the smaller the thing you have to do I
remember um actor Timothy spall
Great British actor great at comedy he
was in he was like my valet in Enchanted
he's been in everything you'd know you
know if you saw him yeah he told me a
story once he goes uh a buddy of mine uh
was doing Romeo and Juliet on stage and
he had one line and it was when the
capulets the Montague's got together had
this big fight whatever and his line was
come up and break up the fight
and he had one line to break up the
fight that was in he's like going over
his head because and the line was uh
part fools you know like that was it and
he says of course just ruminate and
think and think and think and think over
and I'm thinking
the fight happens whatever because fart
pools
oh no your mind is just always going to
screw you fart pools yes you're just
gonna you're gonna
overthink it to death
and the worst thing I mean you know like
I like Direction when I get on set you
you the worst place to be is self-aware
right the worst place to be is
is to be in that space where you're
thinking I suck I'm a fraud I can't you
know you have to be able to shut that
voice off and go for it and I think the
willingness to fail is essential yeah
it's vital you have to be like I said
before in the hands of someone who will
allow you to do that that not every take
has to be perfect that they're gonna you
can find the right one you can find that
so you kind of have to like you know
stuff that down and be able to go for it
and look like an ass yeah and so I got
very comfortable with looking like an
ass on set because you kind of have to
do that to go you know but in early on
you're like well if I look like an ass
too much if I'm really my pitch is way
off on this scene yeah people are gonna
go well you're not very good we're not
gonna we have to recast or right you're
not gonna be cast in a but I think
you know for me it's like that I know
that vulnerability is already there I'm
always there and that sort of self you
know like
um am I going to be able to bring it
today yes another thing about what we do
is right like if I was a carpenter
you know I I know every day I don't
question whether or not when I wake up
every morning whether I can build a
house right you know you can go build a
house it's not reliant on Mojo oh right
I'm focused mental focus of just like
yeah and all of these other elements
that are constantly trying to yeah take
you out of it which is what is the
technique this is an impossible question
so I'm really just asking for us to talk
about it it's like when you can't find
it what do you do I like I improv I'm
like and I ask about it I'm like can I
just get off the page because I'm seeing
it in my head yeah and it's taken me out
of like being present with this person
looking at them in the eye yeah I'm not
trying to rewrite the script I'm not
trying to do that I just need to shake
this off yeah and find the intention of
the scene yes whether it's these exact
words or not and just mess around and
play with it and then hopefully that
will loosen me up and bring me back to
what's like kind of on the page wow
Jesus because you lose sight of you know
the real the intention of what's going
on in the scene and and um so once you
start are to get in your own head that
way it's a real slippery slope yeah
absolutely that's the worst part is it
builds on it so yeah yeah it's like in
my audition you're going too fast and
now you're not only nervous about the
audition you're nervous that you're
going too fast right right right
oh yeah it's snowball like oh God and I
I have this fantasy after the fact that
I wish I had just gone like can we stop
like I just want to stop right but then
you're also like
this is this is weak have you ever been
I know that's weird to say it's weak but
you're trying to sell yourself as a
professional and your ability so you
don't want to be the guy that goes like
let's stop unless that is the most
confident thing well sometimes that's
what you kind of like the worst thing is
to keep trying to ring something out of
that when you're just already Twisted
yourself into a pretzel like to feel
like you have to force a good
performance out like yeah you're really
because this is one this is you know
this process isn't something that the
more you know Grunt and grit you put
into it the better it comes out right
it's the quite the opposite right it's
like you have to you have to allow
yourself to have you know I don't know
to be comfortable and and not
um you know oh get get in your own head
well let me ask you this because
speaking of gosling who we sort of got
off I can't believe I allowed that to
happen I'm just kidding I'm not even
that obsessed with them uh I just for
sure it used to be a thing on the show
was would always talk about Gosling and
I have a joke about him it doesn't
matter tell me a little bit about not
killing on set like sometimes I want to
kill on set like I want the crew to do
well I want my co-stars to be impressed
but I just rewatched I had a long flight
and I like when I'm traveling solo I
like watching all these movies about
like lone male characters like Blade
Runner with the new Blade Runner and I
was watching that and I was like this
guy and I'm not trying to get you to
talk about him I want your experience
he's doing very little it's a lot of
quiet what do you say you wanna you
wanna get out of here it's like that
like very small they got the boom guys
what yeah yeah and very minimum moves
right you know it's specific build the
tension so kind of a snooze I bet to
film that movie I don't mean that like
maybe it wasn't Robin Williams and Patch
Adams going like no he kept us going
right you mean for the set yeah he's
getting out of the car and it's raining
and it's just that's take one and take
two he's getting out of the car and it's
raining everyone's like Jesus Christ I'm
hungover you know what I mean yeah but
can you talk about that like you're
playing it for the movie not the sure
not the people around absolutely is that
a Temptation though but to kill for the
crew of course yeah like you always you
oh I like I certainly always feel like
is this enough am I just this is
completely dull and and
I just want to apologize to them oh yeah
like you guys he's on a 150 zoom over
here so I can't do too much that's right
right and then when you watch the movie
and it's like and then it's zooming in
it's like oh God this is amazing but on
set everyone was like chewing gum right
like just bored out of their mind no
it's and you're thinking about you're so
when you lost in your life somebody's
efficient what actor told me this once
he said you have to have the courage to
be boring sometimes and and it's not
boring necessarily it's like
you don't want to be you know trying to
jump through the hoops and like I'm
spinning my plates and I'm also juggling
for the audience you know like you you
wanna if especially if the scene calls
for it right and like I said the
technical element of it right I'm not
going to do that if I know it's a master
shot and they're on a 28 millimeter lens
right okay yeah no one's gonna see any
of that right but if you get into a
close-up or whatever there's a slow very
you know specific Dolly move or whatever
this and like okay I always look at the
camera operator I go where are you and I
feel like yeah head to toe or just yeah
are you at the waist is it a cowboy down
at your your knees or are you here and I
always ask the camera operator like and
he's like here like okay so then you
kind of dial the volume up or dial it
down what you're doing but I'm always
thinking
you want it to be more powerful than the
film you know you want the the Restraint
of like keeping it you know keeping it
simple like you just you know
Illustrated with Ryan and and yeah uh in
Blade Runner yeah you know when you see
Michael Corleone yeah right and The
Godfather like
hey was he you know was that just as
gripping for the crew no when he was
doing it yeah or was it like
this guy's just kind of like barely
talking and yeah and he has one
expression and yeah you know it's like
and then you watch the movie and you're
like it's a [__] Masterpiece yes and
he's brilliant right and the only moment
his eyes go a little wide is right
before he shoots the guy in the cafe
with a gun in the bathroom right you
know but beyond that his cold stair
was like his trademark and that whole
marriage to be boring is so yeah you
should drive to entertainment Access
Hollywood after this and just go like I
did it I was a podcast guest because
you're looking for that one thing not
really but I mean like if you can do an
episode where there's one line the one I
was going to share with you is actually
I've said it a million but I'm going to
say it to you is game developers have a
saying where they go fail faster find
the fun meaning you have to have the
courage to be boring you have to have
the courage to try something stupid and
if you're [__] up if you're failing
after you have the job right that's
actually a good sign like as a comic I'm
trying these lines and I'm always going
a little too far I don't mean by today's
standards I mean I I took the concept A
little too far right it was a little too
mean to my mom or something and I'm like
okay we found it right but that's good
those
yeah right yeah
I'm a race like I love driving I'm a big
like F1 fan and like I've done a lot of
like do you race I was training for a
while with Ferrari to get my and my imsa
license to train to to race in their
proprietary series but covet hit and it
sort of stalled that but I do a lot of
carting with my son who's 22. we kind of
share that together
um and that's the same thing right like
you're not going fast enough if you're
not going over the educationally like
you're not you're not getting better
right and you're not you're not gonna
win the race right if in training you're
not spinning out you have to spin out
you have to like crash you got to get
off you know off the line and but that's
it it's finding that edge and then you
go okay well that didn't work well now I
know how to Pivot the limit right yeah
and you come back to it and creatively
the same thing yeah and and if you're if
you're on a set that allows you to to do
that to affords you the ability because
not always that's always the case right
sometimes it's like we gotta go I'm
gonna have time for like you know
discovery right right right and also
like
the the technical aspect of filmmaking
right like I can't uh like maybe I'll be
over there like we'll have lunch in five
minutes I can't relight the set right
that's right you got to make this work I
think people would be surprised at how
it's not that it's rigid but I just did
the the thing that I was shooting their
kids and you can see that the kids just
are less experienced and they don't know
it's like continuity stuff right there's
a lot of things where you're like where
was it where was my arm right at the
beginning of this tank it was this
because you you don't want to yeah you
look stupid well you want it to be able
to cut right like they can't use this
now because you picked up a napkin and
put it on your head in that take that's
right right I'm gonna say though nobody
really tells you that you kind of figure
it out slowly you think someone would go
like welcome to acting you know maybe
maybe you took a class or something film
acting but I just like slowly put it
together I was like oh right this is why
because I was playing it to the crew
right let me ask you here's another uh
it's a gosling inspired question you
mentioned Brando I think Ryan's from
Toronto or something uh it's definitely
Canada Canada yeah but I don't know I
don't know where it talks like he's from
New Jersey I would say this to his face
this isn't shots fired yeah he built a
guy he made a guy I also built a guy I'm
not from the Midwest but occasionally on
stage I'll I'll just go into like a
backpack with snacks because it's funny
right right so I know I'm from Boston I
don't even there's even I even upped the
sort of there's a like a I don't know
how to say it
uh a wispy quality that I realized was
funny so I'm more like James like
because that's funny almost like Paul
Lind I guess you could say like I
realized oh my God oh my God I turned up
that a little bit
secret down Center Square
have a funny story about that secret
Dallas
I want to hear your pollen story I'll
put a bit of this yeah but no no no once
you continue no no you're talking about
like just kind of putting on a bit of a
character as a person like realizing it
became I don't just do it when I'm on
stage because you do it voluntarily are
you aware of it no no no it's absolutely
same voluntary I uh my Persona on stage
changed slowly and then it just became
who I was but I would defend that saying
it's not like the first version of my
voice and my personality was real there
is no real right you're just absorbing
from your environment oh my mom says
this my dad says that my friends talk
this way yeah and then you slowly and I
think don't forget Paul in I think Ryan
was very smart but he was also very
honest meaning uh Bob Dylan can sing
like this right you know what I mean
he's like I'm gonna do this right and
listen to anybody Billy eilish they're
all affecting an affectation yeah it's
it's and you could say you could be
holding Caulfield and back and be like
that's phony right or that's kind of
your job so Ryan Gosling realized that
there was a gap to be filled with
Leading Men you know what I mean that
he's like they need this Jersey accent
they want toothpick voice right the guy
that goes uh well you know I'm gonna
wait you're from Vancouver or whatever
it is right right and he doesn't say
sorry he doesn't say sorry you know what
I'm saying right no yeah he doesn't I
think maybe I'm wondering if you did
that and what do you thought I mean if I
do it I do it involuntarily and I'm
unaware of it but but I I know that
sometimes those little devices I guess
you could call them whatever where
you're you they help you into the
character a bit more like it's kind of
like putting on a part of your costume
right yeah where you can go it the
hardest thing for me to play is myself
um right if I if I play a character
that's outside of myself it's way easier
so if I actually
you know invoke or if I even just com
create some little affectation like you
said it's one step closer to like
immersing yourself in whatever character
is coming next I don't know maybe that's
maybe kind of what he's doing I think so
easier to step outside of yourself so
that you can be this other thing but
then also and I'm not trying to be
College lava lamp smoking a Dube in our
dorm room but the he's also we're back
to where we were 30 minutes ago a movie
star is also a character he's playing
right and they don't want right you
don't want Ryan Gosling or James
Morrison on the red carpet being like I
like Blade Runner or Harrison Ford right
Harrison Ford isn't always like this is
not this is this is this is So Meta
because the the the Paulin story
involves Harrison Ford get the [__] out
of here I swear I've been like crazy
building you
I'm like wait how yeah you've dug deep
like you would really intimate I mean
yeah uh tell me the Lynn story so
I don't know how I how I oh I learned
about Paul in because I did bye-bye
birdie in high school and in the movie
he played uh the father of
um the of um forget the actress who
played anyway but um like who's this guy
who comes in does talks like this that's
his thing and are you guys talking to my
naturally born with Children what state
was and then I was like so he wasn't he
was famously gay right I mean like yeah
I mean I don't know when that happened
when it was if it was in the 1960s when
he was doing glass bottom boat or
whatever but he you know that was a
funny time right wrong Rock Hudson right
exactly Liberace right right I don't
know when it officially you know it
became Public public knowledge but but I
thought he was so funny like who's this
guy who's this character and then my mom
was like oh yeah he's Center square on
Hollywood Squares and yeah
um this is where you're by the way your
gen Z audience tunes right out no they
love it what the [__] is Hollywood
Squares they buy VHS tapes of it on
online right and watch it ironically
like who's this guy's gonna interesting
like you know voice and whatever and
it's got his thing and it was like you
know I was like Joan and then Joan
Rivers I think came and replaced him but
they're like you know to Paul in who you
know what state was Abraham Lincoln born
in he's like oh pretty much like all of
us naked and screaming a lot
and my buddy I don't know I was I did
that for a friend of mine and he was
like you do a really good Paul in it was
actually Tate Taylor the director of the
help he's like well let's make a Paul in
movie and have you play Paul in
but before that I was on the show Ali
McBeal with Calista Flockhart and was
you know big big hit in the early 2000s
and when we were when we wrapped the
season she started seeing Harrison Ford
or she was going on one of her first
dates and she said please because I got
to be somewhat you know close and
friends with her come to this dinner I'm
with Harrison Ford and me I don't want
to go alone uh it's very early on
when she shows up and you're there hey
Clarissa that's exactly
why are you bringing and it was the
other guy on the show too my friend Josh
Hopkins yeah yeah it's like oh boy
and it was you know he was very nice but
it was like okay when's this gonna end
and I can just kind of be alone with
this girl I want to take out yeah and he
was very very we laughed it had a nice
little meal and we went back to his
house
and um I think now the statute of
limitations and I can talk about this
stuff but if I'm wrong feel free to cut
it out and he was very gracious host and
was making us drinks he was sitting
there and somehow we started talking
about Impressions and my friend Josh
who's on the show did an impression of
Harrison without him and he walked in he
goes I want to hear this so he did the
you know the scene with Greedo he's like
I don't have it with me you know
slow talk Harrison Ford bit and you know
I don't I just going to see your boss
and like yeah anyways Harrison kind of
like gave a smirk it was pretty good and
then we had a drink or whatever and then
somehow Paulin came up and I went to a
football in and he threw his head back
and started howling with laughter and
got on his knees on the ground was
laughing he was like how do you know who
Paul Lind is he's like that's the best
pollen I've ever heard like yeah maybe
maybe made me feel good so when you said
Paul in I had to indulge myself you
should tell that story when I said how
are you you should have been like one
time
well well funny you should ask
it's kind of shitty whether I'm not
paying these taxes for this kind of
weather here in L.A it's been raining
ties which one of these doors do I open
in a giant boulder chases that's what I
would have said at his house yeah that's
it I heard Harrison that yeah that you
weren't the original choice for for uh
for Indiana Jones I heard they were
gonna cast Paul in but he was busy be a
whole other movie give me that bag of
sand for this Idol Oh my God okay anyway
we're gonna go to the mid-roll ads okay
and then and then we'll be back
healthy hydration guys let's talk about
it it's not about just drinking water
it's about drinking water plus
electrolytes which makes sense when you
sweat you lose both water and sodium and
both need to be replaced to prevent
muscle cramps headaches and energy dips
but most people are only replacing water
why because since like 1942 people have
said just drink eight glasses of water
that's pretty much the end of our
hydration education but drinking Beyond
thirst is actually a bad idea it dilutes
blood electrolyte levels which leads to
headaches low energy cramps confusion or
even worse and the solution to getting
through your workout or just getting
through your day with proper hydration
to optimize your body and your mind
isn't just drinking water it's to drink
water plus electrolytes which in the 90s
meant drinking like a flat soda with 900
grams of sugar that's where we got our
electrolytes in the 90s it was a weird
time now we have something better drink
lmnt element drink element element tea
has become a huge part of my wellness
program personally and a big part of my
morning routine that I sincerely look
forward to every day it's the first
thing I do in the morning is I get a big
glass of water and I stir in a packet of
element tea I like their flavor
watermelon salt that's my favorite you
mix it up boom takes 10 seconds and you
are good to go it jump starts my day
makes me feel ready to face my day and I
know I can feel good with no sugar or
artificial junk just electrolytes and
great taste and I believe it's like five
calories which works for me because I do
intermittent fasting this provides the
optimum ratios of sodium potassium and
magnesium excuse me for health
performance and energy it also tastes
amazing if I'm fasting like I mentioned
It's a Wonderful way to satiate my mouth
desire to taste something to sip
something that's tasty without eating so
it not only helps My fasting when it's
in my gut but it helps My fasting when
it's in my mouth because it you know
sometimes you're just bored and you want
to taste something delicious without
breaking that fat fast lmnt has you
covered and they have a fantastic offer
if you guys want to take your hydration
to not just the next level but to the
appropriate level where that water is
getting into where those minerals are
being replaced for your workout for your
day for your mental cognition I'm going
to say cognition Elementary as a special
deal for weirdos just go to drink
lmnt.com weird and use promo code weird
to get a free element sample pack with
any order when when you use this code
and if element doesn't element doesn't
exceed your expectations they offer a no
questions asked refund policy you don't
even have to send it back so support
your body support the show go to drink
lmnt.com weird and get your free sample
pack with any purchase this is zero risk
drink lmnt.com
weird it's also brought To Us by our
friends at Pym choose what is pya am Pym
is prepare your mind prepare your mind
choose help you manage feelings of
stress anxiety and overwhelm if I'm
being honest that's a big part of my
life is trying to manage feelings of
stress anxiety and overwhelm and it's
wonderful when you're feeling worried
stressed out or just have that be in the
belly kind of feeling that is just
unsettled and it keeps you from working
keeps you from enjoying the moment for
me it's a huge thing I just can't face
my email inbox because I'm just too
anxious I take a couple Pym choose and
within minutes you start to feel more
centered calm and in control they're
delicious naturally flavored no sugar
added and chemical free when I first got
these there I thought they were too good
to be true they made me feel so calm and
so in that good flow Zone I sent a
subscription to my mom I sent a
subscription to my brother just so happy
that anxiety and stress have a natural
non-addictive non-psychoactive solution
I like taking it start on my day
sometimes I take at the end of my day
I've been known to pop a few during any
Zoom anyone else out there just get
freaked out by Zoom Pym choose are
comprised of proven amino acid complexes
and adaptogens that help support your
brain and your body's ability to
organically support and your own ability
your organic ability to manage and
tolerate stress anxiety and overwhelm
Pym it's a beautiful company on a
mission to end the stigma surrounding
mental health and to make a better mood
accessible to all and a percentage of
their profits goes towards mental health
nonprofits including bring change to
mind so do your anxiety your overwhelmed
and your stress a favor by annihilating
them naturally and gently with this
effective and natural way to give your
body the nutrition it needs to fight off
stress I'm so happy to say it works it's
a wonderful Ally here in the house and
you can try it as well and show your
support of the show go to
ucanpym.com weird and use promo code
weird for 15 off that's you can pym.com
weird use promo code weird for 15 off
all right everybody back to the episode
and we're back
terrific God I gotta buy me some of
those you you could drink that one right
there yeah if you want this one there's
a two this is like the blue pill on
water that has stuff that's good for
your metabolism and prevents muscle loss
there you go hmb that's what it is what
is hmb you're gonna have to perform the
side of it I just like to drink it just
questions later well that's the magic
mind because you said you wanted coffee
that's what you want magic a little jolt
a little jolt it's more do you remember
jolt do you remember twice the caffeine
half the sugar it started as a bet as a
bet yeah that was the lore I think
that's fake but Jolt Cola somebody was
like I bet you can't make this sounds so
fake but I believed it as a kid you
can't make a Coke knock off twice the
sugar half the caffeine and then later I
think they changed the recipe to make it
like more caffeine or I don't know about
the sugar yeah I yeah I remember that
stuff do you remember the toxic okay
soda no we're about the same AJ Okay
Soto is a Gen X so okay and it tasted
like a suicide remember suicide yeah so
I'm just gonna say when you've got every
drink from the new year because I've
been reading your mind
tell me what happens tomorrow in my life
you have a very satisfying BM I'm sorry
but that
BM you love it do you have a bidet
I don't but uh I need to get one yeah
they're not you never see them but it
makes the Japanese one that's just on
your seat is this the Toto whatever this
is okay all right it's not a sponsor
right not sponsored but I hear they're
great they are great they're great I'd
love one uh yes send one James Mars
didn't just write why are there certain
things that we are yeah and sort of like
you know Stone ages on like why is that
something that we haven't embraced as an
American culture it's everywhere else
right why are we just yes we're like we
don't know I think it's a new planet car
you don't want you wipe it with a leaf
and you move on
like that's the American way it is a
little grit do you remember this
stranded stranded stranded on the toilet
bowl can't find the paper roll so you
take it like a band and wipe it with
your hand do you remember that no
no that's in the like uh uh there every
other one I can think of was doesn't age
well but there is something about like
in America
puritanical culture
anything with your butthole
don't talk about it minimum and don't
talk about it certainly don't sprinkle
it with a gentle warm water flow it's
too sexual it is think about that's
probably it you're in Paris and you're
like these guys are tickling their
buttholes after every poo poo yeah
you're supposed to wipe it poorly have
it itchy and go eat more meat like that
meat that's the American way clog up
that colon that's the American way yeah
yeah hey your mom was a nutritionist
what was that like did she teach you
good stuff did she like set good
patterns or was she kind of cuckoo she
she did both she did both she did I we
didn't have the healthiest stuff growing
up but it wasn't unhealthy I mean beans
Browns yeah no I mean wheatgrass what
kind of nutritionist was she I think she
just was she was like as clean as we can
eat the better yeah right yeah it was
like and in Oklahoma City that's you
know not easy that's just going to
Arby's and not eating the bun is that
true no I mean if she used to do the
napkins yes if she predicted Atkins true
yeah true true no I mean there was a lot
of a lot of like home cooked meal you
know chicken fried steak and big
unhealthy thing oh really yeah okay so
she was in Oklahoma City she was in
Oklahoma City yes in Oklahoma nutrition
early fries are actually easier to
digest yeah right about the shape right
it's like the DNA Helix it helps the BMS
the curly fries and then we wipe it Pour
it itch all day then eat more meat
that's the American way is it true that
I'm gonna get off base now John Wayne
have it was is this a joke in
I think oh I'm realizing this is a joke
in one of the jackass movies that some
guy one of the guys shoves something up
his oh yeah
yeah the Hot Wheels car whatever yeah
the race car shouldn't have said Hot
Wheels the uh the small miniature
diecast it wasn't a micro machine micro
machine doesn't make the move past that
easy that's when you have to listen to
the fans that's the Sonic that's the bad
looking original Sonic of that movie
it's got to be a bigger car
not at least an eighth scale yeah not
right a quarter quarter mile with the
working doors if the doors work it's too
big to put up your butt I've always said
that I think he said something about the
guy was was trying to help him get it
out saying that John Wayne had like 60
pounds of of oh poo poo in his yes and
he's like is that why they call him the
Duke
[Laughter]
doubt it you see
certain corn fed uh yeah all their no
fiber none yeah just yeah why is it
manly to have absolutely no flow down
there I don't know I don't I don't know
but yeah I mean yeah the day makes sense
yeah you know no you got to get one but
like you're right oh the Botanical part
of it like oh for sure this is uh well
thank you God would not approve of
something tickling that yeah if he
wanted something to tickle it it'd make
it easier to pee on your own butt wait
someone's done that the original bidet
crossed my own life the self-made
you a U-Boat back to your phone oh okay
yeah yeah this Rift is horrible horrible
have you ever almost died have you ever
seen a ghost have you ever gone to a
psychic or some sort of phenomenon that
you can't explain no and I'm the guy
that wish yeah yeah uh I remember going
back to going back to X-Men the actress
Famke Jansen came in one day and she was
kind of rattled I'm like what's up she's
like my my apartment's haunted and I was
like it is how and of course I'm just
saying I'm like oh yeah what they look
like just stop stepped up I know you're
taking the piss but like I said what
happened well her dog at the Times named
Licorice and she's like licorice for no
reason like got up and stood and looked
into the corner of this room where there
was nothing there started barking at it
and I think that's it
and and I said but licorice has been
doing it for three years
I feel bad because she lost the dog
recently no no it's a while back it was
a while back but I was like it's a mouse
in the wall of the right behind you know
she's like you're never gonna see any of
this stuff because you don't allow
yourself to believe it well and you know
we're close friends so she was you know
just jabbing me but I was like was that
all it takes to believe just just
believing in it that was true I would
have seen a lot more yeah than I've seen
right it would it would be a hoot it
would be a hoot uh not in the moment but
afterwards you'd be like wow that really
affirmed that there's a lot more going
on here there's the Albert Albert
Einstein is purportative say there's two
ways to look at the universe one that
nothing is a miracle one that everything
is a miracle right and if you see
something unexplainable it's kind of
you know yeah affirming that more is
going on here especially with ghosts
it's like an afterlife kind of right uh
where do you stand on that on the ghosts
I think you're always safe not in public
opinion necessarily but you're always
safe in assuming that this thing yeah
that we're in is so much weirder than oh
anyone thinks I agree and no matter how
many people I'm not putting down science
right no matter how many people in white
lab coats label it right and recreate it
it's still a [__] yeah not a [__]
show but it is a mystery it's a mystery
you're alive you know you're alive
there's like the shapes of amoebas
mirror the shapes of animals in the
shape the universes and molecules and
all this stuff I was like there's this
weird thing going on so the fact that
you draw the line
I had a bit about this but I'm gonna put
it to you it's like people don't believe
in an afterlife and afterlife is just as
Preposterous as a life you showed up out
of nowhere into life and you're like
there's one [__] weird thing that
doesn't make any sense and then that's
it I was like I don't understand right I
understand also how it's narcissistic to
be like I must continue I'm just saying
like don't take anything for granted
well yeah honor the sort of Miracle of
not necessarily knowing all there is to
know right because it's it does get
arrogant to think that this brain that
was created by something yes has the
capacity to understand things all of the
levels that right and why would that
even serve it that's what they're seeing
now so brain science is saying like the
chance that your brain is showing you
reality is zero I think it's like zero
point something because it would be too
overwhelming right it would only show
you a version of reality like the
Communist party like propaganda right
your brain shows you a propagandized
version of reality to favor your
breeding your survival safety your food
why would it go like there's also a
pirate right here you know what I mean
I died choking on a fishbone like that
doesn't happen
like oh [__] my brain is just
prioritizing different stuff or I'm like
tuned differently
if you want to if you want to get in the
skeptic tank all right Shapiro's podcast
if you want to get in a skeptical place
I can rock out on the pleasure of that
too a little bit more certainty like if
my daughter was afraid of a ghost I
would be like sweetheart there's no such
things as ghosts maybe later in her life
I'd be like remember what I said I don't
know
I've heard some stuff right but you
would like to see something well yeah I
just because I my brain is structured
around more around fact and like science
and I wish it wasn't yeah
um because it's like for the fun it's
it's like Faith right like
things that we can't see like we're
conditioned I think it's people to be
like well like talking about fear and
survival and and and and and uh all
those things that sort of dictate how we
get through life and what drives us and
whatever and how we feel and what makes
us feel safe why okay I know that this
pillow is going to be here when I reach
over and touch it again and like you
know yeah
um but the idea of sort of a belief
something's going on with that your eyes
can't see right so much of it is like
what can we see what can we touch what
can we smell what can we be what can
what's constantly been reaffirmed to a
reproducible experience right right
every time I touch this right and you're
like okay this makes me feel stable
right right and then Zion says what if I
hit it harder right what if I hit it
softer what breaks it right and then
you'll get another one yes and then we
go we're very sure that this is real
right yeah right and then so within that
like you know I I don't know I wish I
I wish I had more of those like I have
there's you know so religion or
spirituality like I'm I'm definitely
somewhat spiritual in a sense that I you
know I my my sort of feeling on all of
that is like
I am so I don't I have no idea yeah if
there's an afterlife I have no idea
what's beyond what my mind can
comprehend or see or touch but I know
that there's something there there's no
there's a [__] ton there right but I
don't know what it is right necessarily
and I'm like my Marvel at what that kind
of is or out you know or could be but um
yeah but I guess sometimes like you get
you get wrapped up in the the things
that you know living a day-to-day life
right like I know that
that kind of thought sometimes that has
its place of course and but I eventually
I still have to get out go and pull that
doorknob open the door and get in my car
and press the gas pedal and like all of
these things that we know that we have
right um and I think that provides a lot
of like security for some people you
know it would be too overwhelming too
overwhelming right in fact that's what I
was just talking to somebody about this
that's what psychedelics do your brain
is prioritizing what's important in this
room right and when you take
psychedelics uh it stops doing that
right and guess what you're not really
useful
right you're having a YouTube but like
if this texture becomes as interesting
as it actually is without getting too
much into what reality is but like as it
you perceive it to be you could stare at
it for hours but you're not breeding
you're not eating right and you're not
you know right right preparing for
tomorrow all the things that made us
right right as a species right moving
forward and yeah right right or even
though animals animals plant isn't that
weird like squirrels are planning for
the winter beavers are making a damn to
have a habitat like that's wild even
though yeah they're present they're
planning bearers are planning isn't that
insane it's insane I'm actually just
thinking about this kind of for the
first no I know and I think with nature
and Wildlife especially those kinds of
things like I'm I actually you know I
mean I have three kids and I've
witnessed each one of them being born
and like gross you know
[Music]
gross
I I wish I could take a psychedelic and
do it again right it was so amazing did
you not take a psychedelic one for yours
no you wanna you wanna take it I
actually knew a friend who smoked
something very strong and went back and
saw his kids be born again which I was
like whoa wow yeah
I don't have much um experience in that
world I don't uh it it I my ex-wife who
I'm still very very close with thank you
um yeah uh before Instagram handle I'm
just kidding just give it a plug
she doesn't think she's on Instagram she
uh she was the first person I spoke to
joint with and she gave me the joint she
goes I'm gonna run to the bathroom you
try it out I'll be back and I thought
you smoked it like a cigarette I took 10
cigarette hits off this thing my first
time I ever smoked weed and I was out of
sorts for hours of course I have the
same experience really just like nobody
tells you about continuity weed smokers
just think everyone knows how to do it
and oh God I was like great I want to be
laughing like you nothing is funny right
now at all in fact I could I couldn't
even finish that sentence nothing is
funny like nothing is what was I gonna
say I mean it's like I couldn't see my
hand was floating in front of my face
but really but like because he has a
mild it's a psychoactive drug it can
make you hallucinate uh yeah yeah and
I've I've since discovered sort of you
know lesser uh like versions of that
meaning like oh yes this actually can be
nice and it can't help me sleep or it
can't help me whatever if you're if I'm
writing a song or like you know like
kind of I could see how that the doors
sort of open up a bit you know yeah
especially if those if you know because
I I love music and I play guitar and I
you know I try to write songs and if
you're sort of like
your left brain or whatever is taking
over it's just this is not where you
want to be like yeah you're like ah
you're too judgmental of it this sounds
like a Coldplay song You're fraud or
whatever you're just duplicating yeah
right oh you mean it's ripping off yeah
it's like you know you're just you're
just recreating a Melody that's already
sort of mulling around in your brain
don't even get I think they did a study
back in the 90s that was like we're
going to run out of original melodies by
2010 or so right which I've always kind
of like but I don't know if I can
disagree with that like then you're like
okay well I'm still hearing new music
that's true where did that Melody come
from put me in any supermarket and it's
just my brain always goes this is um Mr
Postman or whatever or like oh yeah this
is I know exactly yeah right there is a
song that's Mr Postman right yeah and
you see the the recyclical nature of but
then it's like there's also no truly new
original way to act per se you can just
kind of mix you can meaning what do you
have you have your mouth your eyes your
net your you know yeah there's a set
amount of notes for your acting as well
right or your writing as well yep that's
what we're seeing with like Ai and chat
is finding out what the notes that we
use are for things but then you realize
that the art is how you use those notes
right yes how that's uh yeah so if you
write a song that sounds like a Coldplay
song there's actually a good chance
that it that might be within the bounds
you know right yeah sometimes I watch an
old episode of Simpsons and I'm like oh
my God I wrote a joke that's so similar
to that joke that I know I saw when I
was 15 right right I'm like and maybe
you're not even aware of it right yeah
at all so you're like oh that's just in
there somewhere but then you go it's
just artists like right like you know
I'm trying to think of I'm sure like Van
Gogh was not ripping off I'm inspired by
Monet or whoever like you know look
you're in probably a completely
different time periods fine nobody in
this room knows that what we thought
Paul in was a deep deep cut we're going
it's great to sit down with marzon and
talk Monet
but you're in a very long line
uh and at the end of the line is you get
to be an artist or an actor or a
musician and if there's an opportunity
to cut the line I don't mean actually
screw people over I just mean like let's
listen to a cold play record figure out
listen to what they figured out and let
that project you forward a little bit
right I don't think there's anybody that
we've heard of that is just a pure
original well that would be ridiculous
right well yeah I mean yeah originality
is is your interpretation of everything
that's happened before you yeah
right right this inspired you maybe
we're seeing it more
not egregious now but it's definitely
like well that was you just kind of went
into the contract and said here as long
as we're seven notes that we're stealing
from this melody and that's right eight
that's right right right
um you know I know a lot of songwriters
nowadays go in and find old Gershwin
tunes and just go oh I love this chord
progression and let's kind of just
change it here and here and you know
it's like already the template is there
it's like when they do a sound to like
yeah like on The Daily Show they had
Back in Black for Lewis Black and it was
done
it wasn't done
yeah they doubled up the note and they
changed
we did that this is the backdrop for the
pet home show we did that for a Cold War
Kids song that I really liked and we
tried to get that song we couldn't
afford it so they did like something
inspired by it yeah you wouldn't even
know but that's just how a lot of people
are like I always think of the James
Bond theme song
so many songs you can go all right they
use that little bit like you can hear it
you can hear it and it's not plagiarism
it's like that's yeah you know that's a
progression well that's
that's you can hear it Hamilton the
musical you can hear it and then Eight
Mile song with Eminem
but it's you know it's not oh I just did
a mashup in my head it was um that's not
my name
[Music]
that's what people say oh Taylor Swift
that's what people say
That's Not My Name yeah I'm not saying
I'm just saying I'm not saying there's
overlap I'm saying we're all in the
ocean right it's no wonder we're a bunch
of fish
Jesus wise words that's exactly exactly
but sometimes like not to go back to
like psychedelics and stuff but I can
see how oh well that actually does get
rid of all of those at least that voice
in your head is going this sounds like
that Yep this is you're you're ripping
off what your choice in this scene is
you're doing a Brad Pitt impression or a
Tom Cruise or you know what they can do
is they make you realize your lineage in
a you're you're moving the ball forward
instead of stealing from Marlon Brando
right you're you're actually honoring
him right by letting him Inspire he's
gone he's dead and now he's he's still
in the scene with you
like going back to what we talked about
earlier too like you were saying that
you you
involuntarily created this not
affectation but like you know a little
bit something
I would do that because I got into this
business because I was a good mimic like
I had an ear yeah
well just before hearing you know voices
and like and it wasn't
it wasn't I wasn't aware of it like when
I was in high school it was like the
impression guy I was like tomorrow does
a great yeah you know Chad from English
like you gotta hear his chat or the
teacher and whatever and it wasn't
anything I was trying to do to get even
get attention I'm just like I would that
teacher whose name would come up in
conversation yeah I'd be like I know
he's like I'm like oh that's a really
good teacher so this is me by the way
and I do this to a fault when I'm around
people take on their their thing same
and I don't know I'm doing it and I've
been in really embarrassing situations
where I do what do you mean I was just
with an Irish guy yesterday and I just
kept going thanks
because when you're with them it sounds
great and again you're probably not even
aware of it but the American thing
doesn't sound great when you when you
keep talking like that but I don't think
we're even making that this that choice
right I don't think it's we're unaware
of making that decision the show that I
just did with a lot of Indian it's about
an Indian family and I just every once
in a while I would just catch myself
um what is it these
I I will like I just wanted to say a v
instead of a w not to do a silly voice
but because this is what everyone sounds
like in the room and I just want to try
it I just have to right it's mimicry
yeah but I understand that uh somebody
was explaining the dynamic it's
different with an Irish person or a
Scottish person because maybe that's my
Heritage so I always had to be very
careful to make sure it was okay right I
can't get offended right like were you
taking the piss or like are you trying
you know because they're aware of it you
might not be I mean are you mocking what
is it what is your intention here right
and for if you sound like me my
intention is an involuntary I can't stop
trying to sound like when I go home I
speak in a Boston accent the entire time
yeah do you speak Southern the whole
time yeah yeah it's not it's not as
heavy as it was when I yeah but you just
do it living there it's just what
happens right it's what we do and it was
probably a survival Instinct that's why
I brought up my parents I was like
trying to act right like they were
acting or what they wanted or whatever
that continues to this day God where
else did I do it that was just
embarrassing that I could probably just
talk about on this podcast I mean hey
hey James yeah this is two guns hey
buddy this isn't three guns okay you go
on your trip
there's one too many guns one too many
guns get out of here uh uh yeah I I I I
I do it and I don't know I'm doing it
and and it served me because I have a
good I don't know I can I can do
Impressions I can do you know yeah yeah
um but uh but I don't like doing it when
I don't know I'm doing it like I said if
you're in a room full of Englishmen
drinking pints you just forget it yeah
no I like listen I did it with the Irish
guys so there was literally an Irish guy
just staying in my house he left this
morning and a couple other guys it was
so great and I would say taking the piss
right I would say having a laugh yeah
Mega oh Mega Man I can't stop no right I
can't stop and I find the Scottish are
in my experience the most like sensitive
to it oh they don't like it yeah because
I love that accent I love this Scottish
accent and I've I've it's because of
Mike Myers they don't like it anymore is
that it yeah I don't know but I mean
it's in every like How to Train Your
Dragon every kid's movie because I you
know you got kids yeah my kids are all
grown up now but like the movies that I
saw for the last 15 20 years are just
like yeah it's all right DreamWorks all
Pixar whatever and yeah half of them are
like Brave
How to Train Your Dragon
you can't do it alone like you know so I
I love that accent and when I'm around
it I just I'm like can I please talk
like you you know and I remember uh
there's some people that are just like
nah I don't like it you know that was
and also you have to do it well because
if you do it shitty then they're not
really not gonna like it well that was
the story I told my Irish friend I was
like I was hanging out with the comedian
David o'doherty and for a month I just
only spoke to him in an Irish accent I
didn't even think about it I mean I
didn't even think to not do it right I
was like of course yeah
please stop please please please that's
enough
oh God that's a [__] Brute
[Music]
um I love it I just I love it it's it's
so I mean I like celebrating it when I
of course yeah I don't know okay so we
kind of talked about God already we kind
of got it oh
barely yeah I just barely did you grow
up religion no uh I did not I grew up
around religion yeah a lot it was like
Baptist giant giant mega churches you
know yeah it was like Disneyland parking
lot churches yeah and nobody was like
why don't you go to church weirdo no
well I remember I mean
no there was like I had a couple of
friends I remember once
a buddy of mine who's really actually
funny actor who's like a friend of mine
that would do like goofy sketches and
drama class with and we went to lunch
one day and came came uh came back and
we were in the car and he turned to me
he's like hey I'm gonna ask you
something I was like he's like will you
accepted Jesus Christ in your life I
knew it I knew when you said let me ask
you yeah and I went
I don't think I have
and he's like well do you wanna and in
my mind I was like well I don't want to
offend the guy or you know I don't even
know what it means it's rude he's at the
door well like sure yeah yeah okay he's
like okay we'll take my hand and bow
your head like in the front seat of a
car wow you can imagine like my my other
friends in high school what the [__] is
going on in there yeah yeah you let
Jesus in your heart and then he does he
leave do you tip him do you tip I mean
he did a service he brought you
salvation are you supposed to is it 20
. yeah I just you know I I don't know I
I uh I wasn't my parents weren't very
religious they weren't um you know
church-goers yeah a lot of people were
just like I mean every Sunday like I
have a place in Austin Texas and it's
right by one of the biggest churches in
town
I drive out of my you know my my little
housing addition and every Sunday like
you know from 11 o'clock to 12 o'clock
there was like 10 cop cars just
directing traffic out of the [__]
parking lot yeah yeah yeah and I'm like
I just want to go get my coffee yeah
yeah damn it God damn you exactly that's
what you're doing it you could go to
Higher Grounds the the coffee shop in
the church I'm sure it's great I'm sure
there's a few options
excuse me cyclops have you accepted
Jesus
he's there he's there I promise let me
ask you one uh one fit handsome guy
question did you get really fat and then
get cut is that a thing everyone has to
do no because I remember Kumail got real
by the way you shouldn't say fat but I'm
just saying like you put on a lot of
weight right and then he got cut wait by
Design like he like purposely got heavy
this is what I understand about Camille
you know who I'm talking about yeah of
course so let's not say of course he's
not that big I'm just kidding I know
I've known him for 20 years so I'm like
is he had of course
yeah and of course I'm just kidding of
course yeah Canal isn't of course and
he's fantastic by the way if I didn't
know who he was I'd say of course
Hollywood
he did that movie with Batista Dave
Batista and I think he followed a lot of
Batiste dips right yeah he just made a
word Dave batip stuff
but tips to Graham for his tips and you
can watch about maybe six months before
Kumail came out as uh Hercules he got
really soft and I talked to him about it
and he was like that's a thing you put
on all this uh extra weight or whatever
and then you cut it like let the thing
grow underneath you that you want to I
guess I don't know I assumed you're a
fit fella I'd love some fit tips I want
some I mean
what do you not do you're not eating ice
cream do you eat ice cream oh yeah get
out of here this is I just I'm so sick
of Gene negative body fat if I get just
put weight on
uh I remember reading When Brad Pitt did
Fight Club he did an interview where
he's like I don't understand all I do is
eat ice cream and hamburgers and I was
like you think that's [__] that's
you're freaking me out because I went to
the fight club and I asked him about his
physique and he said it's a million
calories you gotta eat so much food to
do what that was the only exchange I had
with him to to look like he does in
Fight Club it just made no sense he said
you had to eat a test he was like my
caloric intention 8
000 calories or something like explain
to me the science of that because he
must work out constantly I guess fuel
but like get right you're fueling but
but you would think that not eating 8
000 calories would make his stomach look
like that right I don't have that shot
where he got up off the guy yeah and you
see those gutters yeah I'd I was always
a sort of spindly legged skinny kid yeah
uh drinking spin drift with your spindly
legs yes yeah I was uh I was not the um
the guy in high school that the ladies
were that interested in and I know that
like I picture you through this is
everything and then going here's my
impression of Professor back all right
get around guys no that's definitely
more of that for sure but but no I was
corn-fed Oklahoma boys who were already
225 pounds give me a wellness tip as
somebody who's interested I just started
uh this is so embarrassing but I just
started lifting weights and stuff give
me a tip give me a Marsden tip uh give
me a cyclops tip give me a huge Jackman
tip well yeah
I mean that's become his like another
religion for him I can for some people
like I remember Zac Efron like deciding
to get in shape and it was like he
looked like Camille yeah like good Lord
is there an ounce of fat on your body
anywhere like shrink wrap right he's the
last we eat right right you laugh right
congrats we're gonna be a little grisly
which actually isn't true because you
eat muscle you don't eat fats yeah but
you know
crashes in a plane and everyone's
looking around about how we're gonna
survive and he's just laughing in that
movie chatting for this for years you're
gonna eat me last
but I would say I mean again it's like
what are you trying to achieve are you
trying to gain muscle are you trying to
get out yeah muscle would be nice okay
so yeah you're lifting weights that's a
good thing yeah wow you just started
lifting weights yeah because that breaks
down your muscles and builds muscle like
it's it you kind of traumatize you eat
before you work out or after you work
out if I'm running I'm running yeah I'm
not like Mr Fitness but I like
I can feel you dodging this well I know
the people what what's your protein
intake you eat your weight in grams I'm
not that guy no no no no no no no but I
do know that what I do for a living like
I can't turn into you know late stage
ores and Wells right right I can't I
can't
I can't do it uh so and also I found
like
I don't know I I discovered running and
usually happens when we talk about a
ghost oh yeah yeah now we're this
Fitness talk made the life go with your
Fitness talk we'll use we'll use your
camera right now we're almost done
anyway we're gonna get you out of here
Jimmy you got a big old you know a
little bit of four foot softbox over
here four foot softbox
right that's my Batman costume does that
mean do you know I'm Batman on YouTube
we're both I don't want to say we're
both in the uh
over what's it called the the Canon I'm
not I'm not an of course Kumail uh level
of course but I am uh oh yeah that guy
scroll down as Batman wait wait why do
you have that we do these Batman videos
it's one of the most popular things I've
done we call it bad man he's like an
idiot Batman this is why I'm embarrassed
that I haven't seen it you don't have to
be embarrassed are you kidding I was
just trying to think how to get it back
to me and I was like oh I just work with
the original Batman did you Keaton yeah
the thing I auditioned for was with
Keaton that's why you're kidding so bad
yeah I didn't get it well how long ago
was that the Friday this week yeah it
was recently really it wasn't uh Batman
but it was a yeah Keaton film I met a
few I met him at the the last time I saw
you he was at that party yeah yeah the
the West Side the West boy I was so
nervous at that party I was like I don't
belong here the Cozy party yeah oh
really I mean it was he's lovely but I'm
a huge fan of his I saw you and I was
like that's uh and then remember I saw
you at the Vanity Fair party yeah and I
do you remember this correct me if I'm
wrong because memory is not reliable but
I'm walking out
and I'm I'm just not feeling comfortable
maybe how you felt at the corner party
was how I felt at the Vanity Fair party
and I was like I think I'm gonna get out
of here
I saw the guy on Shark Tank the black
guy
uh yeah really drunk I just remember he
was really drunk and I was like Hey I
Love You on Shark Tank and he was like
and his bodyguards were like stay away
from this guy I was like all right I was
like maybe it's time to get the [__] out
of here like my wife and I rubbernecked
and looked around and we saw Taylor
Swift and right we do that for a good 20
30 minutes and then I actually get
depressed I I really do I'm not saying
that to oh I'm so grassy normal guy I
just don't like being in a room full of
flashlights no not flashlights black
holes everybody's looking for attention
including me but nobody's giving it so
what are we doing here yeah it's just
vapid void yes do you know what I'm
saying I guess you could say it's all
it's all forks and no chicken breasts
right it's all just everyone's going
like who's gonna right who's gonna look
at me and tell me that I'm whatever yeah
and you're like I gotta get the [__] out
of here this is a loser's game I'm
embarrassed to admit but I'm being
honest it's fun to go to a party and and
have people interested in in each other
yeah let's get into this flow going I
hit the tennis ball over the net you hit
it back over that's all I'm saying I
don't need it my new and organic
conversation but real chats right I call
it Movie parties you know in Movie
parties everyone's having real
conversations because there's no music
playing it's a quiet set right and they
have these big scenes and then they play
the music afterwards parties in real
life are like what but that's what
happens when you put all of those types
of people those Personalities in one
room right and it's not a good vibe no
so this is the part and
it's not weird but I'm leaving meaning I
was just gonna say we can edit it out
but it's not like you said something
weird but I was leaving and I had never
met you and I was like and you we you
introduce ourselves and you were like
you're the only person I would talk to
at this point
that was the Cozy thing no oh yeah I
remember I just remember going like I
wonder if you were like me I wonder if
you were kind of having a miserable time
I just didn't know what you meant by it
and I was kind of too depleted to stay
and I was like well we were leaving
another time yeah we were leaving and I
remember our really nice conversation
and exchanges that we had at the other
party yeah and and because I think we
talked about social
awkwardness and all that that was sort
of I remember Jack McBrayer was there
and it was like I don't know what y'all
are talking about you just go around you
hug everybody
vicious because he was like I didn't
know you were paralyzed with crippling
anxiety it's a snake like he's sneaky
yeah you don't expect them
he's getting real dark yeah I actually
got almost to the point where I was like
this is hurting my feelings almost if
you see this Jackie McBee not that's
like no he's so pure and such a good guy
that he does when he offsets that with
his life yeah uh with his viciousness
yeah yeah Relentless yeah is is
mean Jack mean Jack yeah or we call it
real Jack real jacket
am I right in diagnosing that you might
be like me that those that's not
entirely your scene or your comfort zone
I'm I go I still walk into a room like
that I'm like okay well there's there's
Conan O'Brien there's Jack Larry Davis
Larry David there's Judd Apatow there's
you know everyone I'm like oh these are
like you said twice you must have been
near the snack table
[Music]
okay no you mean you're Heroes
yeah it's just like I'm they probably
and I'm like they're looking at me like
um he's he's I thought this was a a
party for this type of person or at this
level or it's a funny because he's like
always thinking like I think most people
but most people think that I don't know
I think a lot of people at that party
probably like I agree with that you know
I agree with that we're all kind of
feeling the same thing but like that was
actually really nice because he's one of
the nicer people yes yeah and I'm
obsessed with him and I have been for a
long time and me and Mac's wife still
we're just like love the guy I think
it's so bright so funny yeah and and um
and but intimidating because he's so
smart and so yeah you know I'm like I
don't I don't know what I think our
exchange was someone brought me over to
say hi to him he's like no I don't want
to I don't want to you know and he's of
course gonna be affable and sweet like
yeah look at you he's like look at you
Jesus she's like have you ever had a you
know non-attractive day in your life and
I was like yeah what do you saying that
what do you say that quick and I went no
no yeah you know he's like oh it's
actually funny
it was I don't know I I was like you
know because I'm a huge Larry David fan
as well I didn't talk to him and then I
yeah I did not it was like the Larry
here's another that's so Hollywood to be
like another Vanity Fair party story I
love it this was last year I walked in
and I was there by myself this time I
had a uh he doesn't get invited anymore
I was very happy to see your face oh
that's so sweet all the homes he's been
too vocal about not liking it I'm just
right just kidding we're not gonna get
any invitations this is fair van v fair
is listening to this podcast going well
right
from Shark Tank again he enjoyed the bar
what does Mrs I think Mrs Fair has an
Irish accent I think isn't she cool
isn't she cool oh
they're so [__] miserable for you
um get the [__] out
I've been thrown out of better magazine
Run Holiday Hollywood Elite parties than
this so tell me that I walked in by
myself to the vetiver thing last year
and like already like that was a
terrible idea
so I'm walking around pretending like
I'm finding the person that I came with
you're holding two drinks just as a
cover yes
I see
cocktail tables right with you standing
at the like a high table yeah and it's
Sasha burn Cohen Isla Fisher Larry David
and these these Larry's either wife or
girlfriend whatever and then another
woman who's chatting with with her and I
know Isla and Sasha so when I was like
this is great say hi to you how's it
going how's the kids
and then uh
Sasha and Isla leave and I turned to
Larry David and the two women that are
he's kind of booking bookending him are
in a conversation and it's me and Larry
David and he's staring at me and I'm
like okay here we go
what am I going to say and maybe it was
like three seconds past but to me it was
an eternity yeah just tongue work like
say something and I didn't say a thing I
just stared at him and we just looked at
each other yeah and he goes
hey
and I was like hey
and I think I probably did the same
thing it was like I did a Larry David
impression because I was nervous yeah
hey
you know
and that was it and then my ex-wife was
like
you didn't talk to me I was like what
the [__] am I gonna say I love your show
well everything that they talk about on
the show like I'm not gonna do a stop
and chat yeah and like it was like this
guy is like I've got no time for you
yeah yeah and it was probably not
void
they like Cyclops yeah I mean you want
to do all of that I said I'm a big fan
and he went don't don't oh I remember
you telling me this yeah yeah that's
that's why that was at the at the party
but also by doing that and him
responding the way he did you got the
Larry David experience yeah he did give
me what I wanted right you don't say big
fat don't say don't sounds
what do I say I tell you what I say what
should I say to you I didn't tell you my
Seinfeld story where he complimented me
and I know and I went I went like this
like like a big like you've just blown
my mind and he looked like I had like I
farted in the elevator like it was like
the like clearly like just too big of a
move yeah and I could see him going like
don't do we have to do the the boom and
then where the shrapnel is flying I've
blown your mind so hard you have to show
me the blast right yes it's really good
he's got me in the blast right now if
[Laughter]
uh he did this movie about the invention
of the Pop-Tart and uh yeah and I'm I'm
in it it's like a it's a kind of a
little Cameo thing but but uh Spike
Ferris is a like a bunny because
Seinfeld oh no Brian Regan has a great
bit about Pop-Tarts how it has
instructions and he goes put the
Pop-Tart in vertically and he goes
[Laughter]
it's so funny does Seinfeld interested
in popstars he's directing the movie and
it's it's called unfrosted and it's
Melissa McCarthy and like Hugh Grant oh
this is a giant cast full of people and
do you like Pop-Tarts and uh
uh I do I do like Pop-Tarts it's not
going back to the fitness thing it's not
on the list of stuff I'm picking up at
the grocery store listen to this rain
I mean little this look at this rain and
you know name drop you know who called
me this morning rain Wilson
Phoenix Wilson
and I went I answered the phone I didn't
even say hello I went it's Ewing really
hard this morning and that the fact that
he didn't hang out tonight
you've been a delight well thank you I
want you to we could keep going
obviously I I'm thinking about who hosts
I don't know how hard out of an out I
have this is too fun I'm truly enjoying
it so so much well I didn't even give
you fitness tips I didn't even well do
you eat before or after a workout I'll
do that after a work after after workout
cardio in the morning cardio in the
morning try to yeah yeah yeah how many
days a week do you work out three three
days a week yeah sometimes none you have
a gym in your house I go to a I go to a
boxing gym in the valley like deep
valley okay uh and how long do you work
out an hour an hour an hour that's a
long time yeah I mean it's average do
you do your legs
uh no
no my spindly legs no I I do I do a
little bit I I just a little I run and I
think that that's gonna that'll be
enough for the legs my legs all day and
it's not it makes them littler it makes
them skinnier yes yeah um but uh but no
I'm not like yeah
you're right yeah we're on the same age
I mean we can't be putting up you and
sunny no no me and you like we shouldn't
be yeah we shouldn't be going to the gym
and like trying to bench 250 no no so
you it my workout would be your
pre-workout I'm pretty sure
5 10 160 pounds like Jesus no well
that's why I started wearing out someone
someone my friend James bashara who made
magic mine told me if you go into your
50s with no muscle you'll just never
have it so I was like okay I got seven
years to that is yeah that is true the
younger you start the more it's gonna
stay with you through your life and I
just got lucky like I was into that a
little bit in high school and college I
had pictures eats eight thousand
calories I don't understand it I mean
it's part of it like at some point you
have to recognize that it's just DNA
like the guys or whoever like some of
the guys who are just built that way
yeah and they eat you know 10 hamburgers
a day and they still look like he's
older than you was he one of your
Inspirations or is he a contemporary I
don't yeah no no he's older he's what
he's like mid to late 50s isn't it where
he's going to be sexy yeah that's a fun
game yeah like who's older Nicholas Cage
or Brad Pitt
is it Nicholas Cage I mean yes maybe
that's not the right but the best one
but by like a year a year yeah Clooney
right or right or Ed Harris right like
what do you mean Ed Harris has been
older whole lives do I really Jones has
been old since always 11. right yeah
it's always been always just been old
actually when I watch no country I
actually get worried because I really
love Tommy Lee Jones and I'm like he
looks like he's close I'm not I'm not
trying to be mad no I'm just like
worried I don't want to lose time really
no no he's I mean whatever from one of
our one of our best yeah he is I mean
yeah it's like boy the people that you
think of as you when you were a kid like
that's a man yeah Tom really right like
Sean Connery people don't know its
measure I can't do it no it's good
that's the point Harrison Ford was 32
when he was Han Solo like that's
perspective like I remember seeing Han
Solo he was the man of that man right I
felt that way and I love Donald Glover
but when I saw him as LAN Endo I was
like but he's a he's a guy like me right
but to kids Donald's a man right you
know what I mean that's when we saw Han
Solo we were like holy [__] right my dad
was like who's this twerp right yeah
yeah I thought it was a different snap
yeah of person that's the same no it's
and also 40 when you were a kid was all
yeah yeah super old was old close to the
Grave yeah yeah yeah just just racing to
death but not too rich we're getting
some light in here this is great nice
yeah the lights coming in we didn't show
you how you're framed but you're gonna
look great
yeah
here like globe
oh what are we eating for lunch Globe
James I guess here today to talk about
how he stays so very round uh well this
is the last question we like to ask
unless there's an area that you wanted
to Circle back to I mean just as long as
it's me yeah yeah yeah if it's me
oriented like I'll talk forever
yes that's what I'm saying no no but I
get a Big Slice of the pie too so it's
it is the tennis ball yeah you're gonna
hopefully my goal is you do this podcast
the rest of the day you feel fed oh
you're like I love it I got enough out I
got enough in the rest of the day is
bonus you think it Access Hollywood yeah
they're probably Pros they're gonna be
great I mean there's something about
sitting here for an hour hour and a half
and I could sit here and chat with you
for we've talked for however long we've
talked and it's felt like did you talk
about anything or do we scrim the
surface and then you listen to it
seriously if you ever listen to it three
years time you'll go like we talked
about every everything yeah it's great
but I feel like we've got so much more
to talk about wait what's the last
question can you think of a time in your
life in your life when you laughed
really really hard and maybe the hardest
Church yeah church is the best in church
yeah Church laugh when you're not
supposed to laugh yeah I went home to
Oklahoma and we would always go to this
this Baptist Church where everyone
lights a candle and sing Silent Night
during Christmas and this is Zach
galifianakis's story is it keep going
and before that happened it's really
beautiful because you see the whole
thing like lit up and everyone's singing
together and it's really nice but before
that I brought you around my wife at the
time with me home to Oklahoma to share
this experience and she's the worst
because
if you know anything gets very serious
she starts laughing like she was like I
had a friend in high school come up to
me and she was crying I'm like what's
wrong it's like my grandmother passed
away last night she's like
we'll start like it's a problem like
it's almost like you know like some sort
of like social
and so when we were in Phoenix yeah we
were there in the church and this woman
came out
and I think because you're sitting there
so rigidly in these pews and everyone's
so buttoned up and like shh you know you
hear candles you're in a title yes
you're hearing them you can't be able to
hear these candles I'm hearing them and
this woman got on stage and she was
doing
some some
Christmas song that had the lyric lamb
in it
and there are two things that happened
one was she started singing she sang
like this you know uh
me Manger
and that's seriously like beautifully
and then I just see my show my my wife's
like shoulders starting to do this which
shakes the entire pew
and you're just like oh I can't I can't
and then they have a screw they have a
the slideshow of images that's going on
behind what this the song that she's
singing and it was sort of like these
beautiful little paintings and whatever
and she gets to a lyric where she has to
sing like like a little lamb or
something like that yeah and you can
tell the people who put the slideshow
together could not find a photo of a
lamb and it's just like all of these
sort of beautifully abstract images and
then there's like this lamb that looked
like it had like
it just had some [__] disease
her singing and then this picture of the
Lamb that looked like it was on its
death's door it was drooling and had
mange it's like and we just started
howling the entire church was like
you know looking back and it's one of
those things like the more you have to
keep it together the more you just lose
it this is a great and that's church is
the greatest place for laughter the best
laughs in my life have been you know
there in that that um sacred place so
sadly this is my religion here you go
you're going it's chill I always good
laughs in church
oh God I'm going to hell
let's hope I'm in good company when I
get there yeah no it'll be great yeah
yeah Jimmy Morrison thank you so much
you got it the light went out the door
is open you were a delight always always
enjoy what I read into you thank you for
doing this podcast I love this made my
made my day you're such a joy always
loved running into you would do this let
me know if you need to keep this couch
warm are you kidding me well you know we
did a bunch of X-Men videos it would
have been hilarious if you play I don't
know if you could if we were doing a
pair because we did these Professor X
videos called X-Men E X Men where I play
Professor Xavier
and I fire the X-Men and my friend Zach
kreger played Cyclops
um I'm not even asking to watch it but
my question is I do want you to watch it
it is could you do that is that in you
like would you get in trouble if you
played Cyclops outside of their
jurisdiction by who I mean I don't know
yeah I mean season desist or something
yeah I don't know I mean that's not even
uh that was when Fox had the yeah okay
so it's changed hands I think is it it's
in the MCU now I don't know well I don't
know it's very mean design but I would
be I'd be a joy to do that well make it
out of storage and put the stuff on do
you have us like relive The Glory Days a
little bit for me it might be nice but
I'm kidding you'll be pleased to know
that the most popular one is Wolverine
because I think Wolverine is a garbage
superhero this is for another time oh
okay it's outside of a bar fight he's
useless right right yes at least you can
laser beam yeah miles away true right
which isn't that fun to to watch right
it's like no it's true right another
conversation on the second film was like
can I do something other than and Brian
was like why would you when you just do
that yeah like well maybe not want to
punch a hole through a mountain every
time that right yeah and he's like work
out something with the stunt guys yeah
did you yeah a little quick little fight
scene thing but there you go but so you
didn't have to do this the whole time
yeah well that was our angle on
cyclopsis that he's a nerd and that and
that the only thing protecting us all
from certain death is a pair of Oakleys
like that that's why he fired something
this is a liability nightmare you need
to get out of here and he fires Rose
yeah
I'll say continuous this is not good
yeah yeah
we have the guests say keep it crispy at
the end it's not a trick yeah it's just
the catchphrase so if you would say keep
it crispy we'll be done keep it crispy
thank you Jim I should definitely oh do
it do it you think we're done
I think we're done keep it crispy
our first well David o'doherty it did he
yeah well [__] David right in the Irish
dear David
oh I think we're done keep it crispy a
fair play too yeah very good
very very good brilliant
[Music]